Remember, when we see a number like 142,
the 1 represents, 1 hundred,
the 4 is, 4 tens and
the 2 is just 2 ones.
We call this the ones place,
this is the tens place, and
this is the hundreds place.
Likewise, in a decimal like 0.627,
the 6 represents 6 tenths,
the 2 is 2 hundredths, and
the 7 is 7 thousandths.
Altogether, this is six hundred
twenty seven thousandths.
The way that we say this number gives
us a clue about how to write it
as a fraction.
0.627 or
six hundred twenty seven thousandths,
would be written as a fraction as six
hundred twenty seven over a thousand.
Using this place value chart,
write one hundred and
nine thousandths as a fraction.
Write your answer in these boxes
with the numerator on the top and
the denominator in the bottom.